يا إلهي ، لدينا أخبار عاجلة صادمة
الليلة من كأس العالم
لكرة القدم الأمريكية تقول إن الصحفي جرانت وول
قد توفي أثناء تغطيته لكأس العالم في
الدوحة غرانت وول زوجة سيلين
غراندر نشرت بيان كرة القدم الأمريكية على
تويتر وكتبت
أنني ممتن جدًا لدعمهم.
عائلة زوجي جرانت وول لكرة القدم
ولديها العديد من الأصدقاء الذين
تواصلوا معهم الليلة ، أنا في حالة صدمة كاملة ، كريستين برينان معي الآن ، هذا أمر
لا يصدق نحن نتحدث فقط عن
كأس العالم وفي ضوء اللقب
تسعة لاعبين و  الآن نحصل على هذه
الأخبار المروعة عن وفاته ، ما
الذي يقوله البيان جيدًا ، أولاً وقبل
كل شيء ، لورا هي زميلة كانت زميلة
وصديقة لي لقد غطيت
العديد من بطولات كرة القدم وخاصة
بطولات كرة القدم النسائية معه
لم يعد هناك المزيد
صحفي كرة قدم محبوب محترم في
البلاد وربما في العالم أكثر من Grant
Wall وهذه
أخبار مفجعة تمامًا ، إنه مذهل
صادم أه إنه مجرد رائع  أخبار
واحدة من أكثر البشر الموهوبين الذين
قد ترغب في مقابلة ما
قالته كرة القدم الأمريكية عند النظر إلى هاتفي
هنا أنهم يشعرون بالحزن عندما علمنا
أننا فقدنا Grant Wall ، يستمر
الأمر لبضع جمل ولكن عشاق
كرة القدم  والصحافة هي أعلى مستوى من
الجودة يعرف أنه
بإمكانه دائمًا الاعتماد على Grant لتقديم
قصص ثاقبة ومسلية
حول لعبتنا وجميع الفرق
وما الذي جعلك تحب كرة القدم
والتزامه بالارتقاء بملفه الشخصي
عبر المشهد الرياضي لدينا
دورًا رئيسيًا في المساعدة على جذب
الاهتمام والاحترام للعبتنا
الجميلة ، وقد يكون الأمر الأكثر أهمية هنا لورا على
نفس القدر من الأهمية التي تقولها كرة القدم الأمريكية في
بيانها حول إيمان جرانت وول جرانت
بقوة اللعبة
لتعزيز حقوق الإنسان كان و  سيبقى
مصدر إلهام للجميع ، فهناك العديد
من الجمل الأخرى ، لكن هذه
نقطة مهمة جدًا لأن غرانت هو الذي
كان يرتدي قميص قوس قزح هذا  منذ
أسبوع ونصف قبل أسبوعين مع
بدء كأس العالم وتم احتجازه
لأني أعتقد أن الأمر استغرق حوالي نصف ساعة
عندما كانت السلطات في الملعب
تخبره السلطات القطرية أنه
لا يمكنه الدخول مع هذا T-  القميص
وما فعله غرانت وول هو أنه لم
يخلع ذلك القميص واحتفظ به
وجلس هناك حتى سمح له أحد المشرفين
عن المسؤولين القطريين في ذلك الملعب
في كأس العالم بالذهاب
للذهاب كما تعلم.  المضي قدمًا والقيام بعمله مع
هذا القميص الذي كان
لا يُصدق جرانت وول لمعرفة أهمية
تلك الرسالة وأهمية ما
يمثلونه على المسرح العالمي في وقت
كان العالم يشاهده
والتفكير في فقدان مثل هذا  رجل محترم
والعديد من الناس يعرفون زوجته سيلين
طاحونة كانت تتذكر عضوًا في
الفريق الانتقالي للمجلس الاستشاري لفيروس كوفيد -19
للرئيس بايدن ، إنها أخصائية أمريكية في
الأمراض المعدية وإذا
كان من غير المعقول التفكير في هذه
المأساة